jeanine áñez retira su candidatura de
las elecciones presidenciales del
próximo 18 de octubre en bolivia las dos
últimas encuestas le asignan apenas un
8% de intención de voto según áñez su
decisión busca ayudar a la victoria de
los que no quieren la dictadura
refiriéndose a un posible regreso del
movimiento al socialismo el partido del
ex presidente evo morales hoy dejo de
lado mi candidatura a la presidencia de
bolivia para cuidar la democracia no es
un sacrificio es un honor porque lo hago
ante el riesgo de que se divide el voto
democrático entre varios candidatos y
que a consecuencia de esa división el
más acabe ganando la elección lo hago
por la unidad de los que amamos la
democracia lo hago para ayudar a la
victoria de los que no queremos la
dictadura
en estas elecciones el ex ministro de
economía y delfín del exmandatario
morales luis arce lidera la intención de
voto representando al partido en
movimiento al socialismo que estuvo 14
años ininterrumpidos en el poder hasta
la partida de morales en medio de
violentas manifestaciones en el país por
supuesto el fraude electoral
en segundo lugar está el candidato
carlos meza del partido de comunidad
ciudadana y segundo en las encuestas
y asumir el mandato transitorio el 12 de
noviembre de 2019 pero su gobierno ha
sido acusado de corrupción durante la
pandemia violación de los derechos
humanos y un mal manejo de la crisis
sanitaria
bolivia está entre los países de la
región con la peor tasa de mortalidad
por coronavirus
un candidato que recupera popularidad es
luís fernando camacho quien empezó a
emerger en los últimos días el líder
regional de santacruz podría convertirse
en el voto de oro para el que será el
nuevo presidente de bolivia